[Music]
I'm all about finding things that make
life a little bit more fun a little bit
more interesting and I think I've
uncovered one this this is something
that I'd like to pass on have an opinion
have an opinion have an opinion have an
opinion I am tired of going to parties
and talking to these opinionist doofas
are just like I don't know either way
you know what I mean I don't know I see
the virtues of both sides get out of
here get out of here go outside and
wander the streets that's an activity
for you you khaki person scrap I like
black and white none of this khaki beige
[__] and I know because I'm kind of
a see both sides person I'm always like
I like chocolate ice cream it's kind of
my favorite but don't get me wrong I see
the value of
vanilla I see it I see it it's a classic
it's a classic it's a classic it's
bright it's bright you can see it in the
dark you can see it in the like it's
like oh there it's like a flashlight
when you get to the smooth part yeah and
cone on a cone did I have to say on a
cone for that to be relatable on a
cone yeah I like it but chocolate's just
it's just more my cup of tea I just like
chocolate a little B shut up me shut up
life is dull life is boring spice it up
if you like chocolate and better than
vanilla just be like f
vanilla vanilla chocolate all the way
baby it's not that you don't see the
quality of vanilla but having opinion is
a shortcut to having a personality are
you listening you can do it with
anything people who like cats cats
versus dogs which do you like well
they're both fun shut
up people who like cats see the good
things about dogs but it's fun to be
like [__] dogs fing dog I feel you
backing
away the point isn't dogs the point is
how much fun I'm having no dogs for me
cats only independent soft they [__] in
a box they [__] in a little box they
know to do that that you don't have to
take them for on a walk like those
codependent [__]
canines who form such a strong bond with
you that their death is devastating
hey thanks for that dogs I'm just saying
cats have the decency to keep some
distance between you and them so when
they go it's just like a neighbor
moving so long it was good kind of
knowing you cat
thank you Cat I can feel a lot of you
being like hearing the words that's not
my point that's not my point it's not
about whether or not I like cats or dogs
because you can do it on the other side
you cats them now I'm losing the other
half of you
fine cats don't
cats do not cats don't if you're
watching this show to determine whether
or not you should a cat you're already
pasted help I can't help you should I
let's see what the TV
says no it's it says no
Martha you already the cat you
[__] arinio said to a
cat that was in his
model you watched you with the sound off
but you heard it you are crazy Mara you
are crazy if this doesn't help you let
live and laugh I can't I
can't